Okay,
so your association task,
the principle is this word association
game.
It's actually predicated,
I would say on psychoanalytic ideas,
most particularly on union ideas because
young development association tests
many,
many years ago,
but it purports to investigate whether
you are unconsciously bias towards one
group against another group.
Could be gender,
could be ethnicity,
could be race,
could be attractiveness,
whatever.
But the problem is is that when you give
the same person that damn it twice,
they don't get the same results.
So there's a rule for diagnostic tasks
and the rule is the reliability test,
retest reliability has to exceed
something like point eight or point
nine,
point eight at least.
So the big five does that.
Iq tests do that,
but there's a dam a,
there's damn few tasks that passed that
reliability criteria and the it is the
only reliable,
I don't remember precisely,
but I think it's about point five,
which isn't even,
it's not even near close enough to be
used as a diagnostic test.
Plus it's not valid.
So what does that mean?
Well,
let's say I assess your unconscious bias
and give you a diagnosis.
Well,
there's no evidence that it predicts
your behavior,
so.
So what?
What good is it?
Well,
it's good if you want people to send you
to retraining exercises so that you can
have your perceptions adjusted in the
direction that your organization in the
state thinks is proper and that's
happening everywhere.
I got letters this week already for
people at CBC.
It's becoming mandatory there at St
Mike's Hospital,
same thing and they've decided that all
of their micro institutions within the
hospital will be equitable.
There'll be 50 percent women and 50
percent men at every single level of the
organization or the organization is
corrupt and oppressive.
It's like it's that.
It's spreading so fast you can't believe
that.
I wrote Mazur Anthony Greenwald
yesterday.
I hadn't set it off to some of my
colleagues say,
are you going to come out and make a
public statement about the fact that
your damn test is being used by
pathological people for nefarious
purposes?
It's like,
well,
we'll see what they have to say about
that.
I was a bit more polite in my letters,
but there's no excuse for it.
There's absolutely no excuse for it and
as far as I'm concerned,
it's part of the broader corruption of
social psychology.
You guys may know or may not.
The social psychology has been rife with
with controversy and scandal over the
last three or four years and a big part
of the reason for that is it's damn
corrupt.
Discipline and that use of the iat for
political reasons is a perfect example
of that.
There is no excuse for it and the people
at St Mike's,
you know,
they say,
well,
this is scientifically validated.
It's like,
no,
it's not and worse.
Let's say you do have unconscious bias
just for the sake of argument and you
could measure it reliably,
which you can't,
and then it was valid,
which it isn't.
Let's say all of those things were in
case there's no evidence whatsoever that
those damn on unconscious bias training
programs,
retraining programs have the effect that
they're supposed to have and there's
some evidence that they actually have
the reverse effect and maybe that's
because people don't really like being
marched off to reeducation by their
employers after they've been diagnosed
as racist.
Even if there's no evidence that they in
fact are so,
it's an absolute misuse of psychology
and it's politically motivated.
It's politically motivated.
It's an assault on freedom.
Anyways,
I made those two videos and I took,
tried to take the HR and equity people
at uft to task because they made that
training mandatory for their hr people.
I thought,
you don't have the right as an employer
to invade the unconscious structures of
your employee's minds and alter their
political perspective.
Even though you can't do it.
You don't have the right to do that and
to think about it as something you
should do.
As a matter of course,
as part of your ethical duty is you
really want that.
You really want that.
That's what you want your employers to
be able to do.
Figure out independently of your
behavior whether or not you're a racist
or classist or or a misogynist or
whatever that happens to be and you
really think that the bureaucrats at the
university,
for example,
or bureaucrats anywhere for that matter
are actually capable and qualified of
doing such a thing properly.
It doing far more damage than than any
possible.
Good.